تاريخ ان شاء الله مع نادي الهلال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كل تاكيد حضور كابتن منتخب البرازيل تتكلم
عن قيمه
فنيه عاليه جدا حضور نيمار للدوري السعودي
حاسه شبيه لو منتخب المغرب حضورهم للدوري
السعودي كله تاكيد يعطي اضافه قويه جدا
للدوري السعودي مع
كريستيانو بنزيما محرز ماني كلها نجوم
كبار وعالميين وعلى ما نسمع انه محمد صلاح
برضه في الطريق كلها كل اللاعبين هذول
بالتاكيد سوف يعطون الدوري السعودي قوه لا
يجتهن بها
كل تاكيد يعني العروض الماليه القويه جدا
كبري اي لاعب يحضر الدوري السعودي كذلك
خوف تجربه جديده في الشرق الاوسط
تعطي ايضا دافع للاعبين الكبار انهم
يحضرون للدوري السعودي
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للاثر
الاعلامي لوجود هؤلاء اللاعبين في الدوري
السعودي بكل تاكيد
له فوائد جدا عديده السمعه الشهره
تعريف العالم باكمله بالبلد السعوديه
شاهدنا العديد من اللاعبين من الجماهير
الاجنبيه تحضر الى مباريات الدوري السعودي
وشاهدناهم بكثافه بكل امانها القنوات
الرياضيه اصبحت تطلب الدوري السعودي كل
هذه الامور شاهدنا على الواقع
البرامج القنوات الرياضيه الحضور الاجنبي
عدم اعداد لمن حصلت قطر في كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
عن طريق
قطر والان السعوديه